success is a five-step process first you  have to know what you're going after  your goals  then you encounter your problems  number two you encounter your problems  on the way to your goals  then  you have to diagnose those problems and  get at the root causes of those problems  and that might be a weakness that you  have or a weakness that somebody has but  you better get at the root cause  and then once you got the root cause  then you can design something you write  down on your to-do list i got to do this  thing that's number four design and then  number five you gotta do it  yes you just can't  say okay now i'm gonna do that thing and  not push through the results  and if you could do that over and over  that's a formula for success you only  have to do those five things you got the  formula for success